Bueno, primero que todo, déjenme dar gracias a Emeka - de hecho,
a TED Global - por organizar esta conferencia en conjunto.
Esta conferencia será una de las más importantes
del inicio del siglo 21.
¿Creen que los gobiernos africanos organizarán una conferencia como esta?
¿Piensan que la Unión Africana organizará una conferencia como esta?
Aun antes de hacerlo, pedirán ayuda extranjera.
También quiero rendir homenaje y honor a los TED Fellows [socios]
June Arunga, James Shikwati, Andrew y los otros TED Fellows.
Les llamo la Generación Chita.
La Generación Chita es una nueva casta de africanos
quienes no tienen tolerancia para con la corrupción.
Entienden lo que es rendición de cuentas y lo que es democracia.
No van a esperar que el gobierno haga las cosas por ellos.
Esa es la Generación Chita.
Y la salvación de África descansa sobre esos Chitas.
En contraste, desde luego, está la Generación Hipopótamo.
(risas)
La Generación Hipopótamo son las élites gobernantes.
Están atascados en su terruño intelectual.
Quejándose del colonialismo y el imperialismo -
no moverían ni un pie.
Si les pides que reformen las economías,
ellos no las reformarán
porque les beneficia el podrido estado actual.
Ahora, hay muchos africanos muy enojados,
enojados con la condición de África.
Ahora, estamos hablando de un continente, que no es pobre.
Es rico, en recursos minerales, recursos minerales naturales.
Pero la riqueza mineral de África no se está usando
para sacar al pueblo de la pobreza.
Eso es lo que hace que muchos africanos estén muy enojados.
Y en cierta forma, África es más que una tragedia, en más de una manera.
Hay otra tragedia duradera, y esa tragedia es
que hay mucha gente, muchos gobiernos
muchas organizaciones, quienes quieren ayudar a la gente de África -
pero no lo entienden.
Vamos, no estoy diciendo, no ayuden a África.
Ayudar a África es noble.
Pero ayudar a África se convertido en un teatro del absurdo.
Es como el ciego guiando al despistado.
(risas)
Hay ciertas cosas que tenemos que reconocer.
El tazón mendicante de África tiene fugas.
¿Sabían que el 40 por ciento de la riqueza creada en África,
no se invierte en África?
Se saca de África.
Eso es lo que dice el Banco Mundial.
Miren el tazón mendicante de África.
Tiene fugas horribles.
Hay gente que piensa que debemos verter más dinero,
más ayuda en este tazón, el cual tiene fugas.
¿Cuáles son las fugas?
La corrupción por sí misma le cuesta a África 148 mil millones de dólares al año.
Sí, hagámoslo a un lado.
La fuga de capitales de África, 80 mil millones al año.
Hagámoslo a un lado.
Tomemos la importación de alimentos.
Cada año, África gasta 20 mil millones de dólares para importar comida.
Súmenlas, todas esas fugas.
Eso es mucho más que los 50 mil millones que Tony Blair quiere conseguir para África.
Ahora, en los años 60, no sólo África se alimentaba sola,
también exportaba comida.
Ya no más.
Sabemos que algo está fundamentalmente equivocado.
Ustedes lo saben, yo lo sé, pero no perdamos tiempo, nuestro tiempo,
hablando de esos errores porque nos pasaremos todo el día aquí.
Sigamos adelante, demos la vuelta al siguiente capítulo,
y eso es de lo que se trata esta conferencia - el siguiente capítulo.
El siguiente capítulo comienza primero, con preguntarnos
esta pregunta fundamental,
¿A quién queremos ayudar en África?
Está el pueblo, y luego están los gobiernos o líderes.
Ahora, el ponente anterior, el ponente anterior a mí,
Idris Mohammed, indicó que
tenemos un liderazgo abismal en África.
Esa caracterización, en mi punto de vista, es más caritativa.
(risas)
Pertenezco a un foro de discusión en Internet,
un foro de discusión africano,
y les pregunté, les dije, "Desde 1960, hemos tenido exactamente
204 jefes de gobierno africanos, desde 1960."
Y les pedí que nombraran sólo 20 buenos líderes,
sólo 20 buenos líderes - quizá
ustedes mismos quieran tomar este desafío de liderazgo.
Les pedí nombrar sólo 20.
Todos mencionaron a Nelson Mandela, desde luego.
Kwame Nkrumah, Nyerere, Kenyatta - alguien mencionó a Idi Amin.
(risas)
Lo hice a un lado.
Mi punto es, no podían pasar de 15.
Aun si hubieran podido nombrar 20,
¿qué les dice eso?
20 de 204 significa que la mayoría, la inmensa mayoría
de los líderes africanos, le fallaron a su pueblo.
Y si lo miran, la camada de líderes post-coloniales -
una variedad de cabezas de chorlito militares.
Socialistas de banco suizo, libertadores cocodrilos, élites vampiras,
revolucionarios charlatanes.
(aplauso)
Ahora, este liderazgo está muy lejos de los líderes tradicionales
que los africanos han conocido por siglos.
La segunda falsa premisa que asumimos
al tratar de ayuda a África,
es que algunas veces pensamos que hay algo llamado
gobierno en África que se preocupa por su gente,
sirve los intereses de la gente y representa a la gente.
Hay una cita en particular - un jefe en Lesotho una vez dijo
"Aquí en Lesotho, tenemos dos problemas -
las ratas y el gobierno."
(risas)
Lo que ustedes y yo entendemos como gobierno
no existe en muchos países africanos.
De hecho, lo que, lo que llamamos a nuestros gobiernos es estados vampiro.
Vampiro porque chupan
la vitalidad económica de su gente.
El gobierno es el problema en África.
Un estado vampiro es el gobierno -
(aplauso)
- que ha sido secuestrado por una falange de bandidos y rateros
quienes usan los instrumentos del poder estatal para enriquecerse a sí mismos,
a sus compinches, a su tribu, y excluyen a todos los demás.
La gente más rica de África son los jefes de gobierno y ministros,
y muy frecuentemente el jefe de los bandidos es el jefe de gobierno mismo.
¿De dónde obtienen su dinero?
¿Creando riqueza?
No.
Lo hacen rastrillándolo de las espaldas de su sufrido pueblo.
Eso no es creación de riqueza - es redistribución de la riqueza.
El tercer tema fundamental que tenemos que reconocer
es que si queremos ayudar a la gente de África,
debemos saber dónde están esos africanos.
Tomen una economía africana cualquiera.
Una economía africana puede dividirse en tres sectores.
Está el sector moderno, está el sector informal
y el sector tradicional.
El sector moderno es la casa de las élites.
Es el asiento del gobierno.
En muchos países africanos, el sector moderno está perdido.
Es disfuncional.
Es un fandango meretricio de sistemas importados,
los cuales las élites mismas no entienden.
Esta es la fuente de muchos de los problemas de África
de donde las luchas por el poder político emanan
y entonces se derraman sobre el sector informal y el sector tradicional,
demandando vidas inocentes.
Ahora, el sector moderno, desde luego,
es a donde mucho de la ayuda para el desarrollo y los recursos fueron a dar.
Más del 80 por ciento del desarrollo de Costa de Marfil
fue al sector moderno.
Los otros sectores, el informal y el tradicional,
es donde encontrarán a la mayoría de los africanos.
La gente real en África - allá los encontrarán.
Vamos, obviamente es de sentido común,
que si quieres ayudar a la gente, vayas a donde está la gente.
Pero eso es lo que no hicimos.
De hecho,
descuidamos los sectores informal y tradicional.
Ahora, el sector tradicional es donde África produce su agricultura,
la cual es una de las razones por las cuales África no puede alimentarse,
y debemos importar comida.
Muy bien, no puedes ayudar a desarrollar África ignorando
los sectores informal y tradicional.
Y no puedes desarrollar los sectores informal y tradicional
sin entender cómo operan ésos dos sectores.
Esos dos sectores, déjenme describirlos,
tienen sus propias instituciones autóctonas.
Primero es el sistema político.
Tradicionalmente, los africanos odian los gobiernos - odian la tiranía.
Si miras dentro de sus sistemas tradicionales,
los africanos organizan sus estados en dos tipos.
El primero pertenece a esas sociedades étnicas
quienes creen que el estado es necesariamente tiránico,
así que no quieren tener que ver
con cualquier autoridad central.
Esas sociedades son los Ibo, los somalíes, los kikuyus,
por ejemplo - no tienen jefes.
Los otros grupos étnicos, los cuales tienen jefes,
se han asegurado de rodear a los jefes
con consejos y consejos de consejos y consejos de consejos de consejos
para prevenir que abusen de su poder.
En la tradición ashanti, por ejemplo,
el jefe no puede tomar decisión alguna
sin la venia del consejo de los ancianos.
Sin el consejo, el jefe no puede pasar ley alguna,
y si el jefe no gobierna de acuerdo a la voluntad de la gente
será removido.
Si no, la gente abandona al jefe,
se van a otro lado y crean un nuevo asentamiento.
Y aun si miras a los antiguos imperios africanos,
estaban organizados alrededor de un principio particular -
el principio de la confederación,
el cual se caracteriza por tener una gran devolución de autoridad,
descentralización de poder.
Veamos, esto que les he descrito,
es parte de la herencia política autóctona africana.
Ahora, compárenlo con los sistemas modernos
que han establecido las élites gobernantes en África.
Son demasiado distantes.
En el sistema económico del África tradicional,
los medios de producción son de propiedad privada.
Son propiedad de familias extendidas.
Verán, en Occidente, la unidad básica económica y social
es el individuo.
Los americanos dirán "Yo soy porque yo soy,
y puedo hacer lo que me plazca, cuando quiera."
El acento está en el "yo."
En África, los africanos dicen, "Yo soy porque nosotros somos."
El "nosotros" denota comunidad - el sistema de familia extendida.
Esas familias extendidas reúnen sus recursos.
Son dueños de granjas. Deciden qué hacer, qué producir.
No tienen que obedecer a los jefes -
ellos deciden qué hacer.
Y cuando cosechan su siembra, venden el excedente
en los mercados.
Obtienen una ganancia, y es suya,
no del jefe para que se las quite.
Así, en breve, lo que teníamos en el África tradicional
era un sistema de libre mercado.
Había mercados en África
antes que los colonialistas pusieran pie en el continente.
Timbuctú era una gran ciudad mercado.
Kano, Salaga - ahí estaban.
Aun si vas a África Occidental, notarás que la actividad del mercado
en África Occidental ha sido siempre dominada por mujeres.
Así, es muy apropiado que esta sección se llame
un mercado.
El mercado no es ajeno a África.
Lo que los africanos practicaron era una forma diferente de capitalismo,
pero entonces, después de la independencia, repentinamente,
los mercados, el capitalismo se convirtió en una institución occidental,
y los líderes dijeron que los africanos estábamos listos para el socialismo.
Sinsentido.
Y aun entonces, ¿qué clase de socialismo practican?
El socialismo que practicaron era una forma peculiar de
socialismo de banco suizo,
que permitía a los jefes de estados y a los ministros
violar y saquear los depósitos africanos,
las tesorerías para depositarlas en Suiza.
Esa no es clase de sistema que los africanos han conocido por siglos.
¿Qué hacemos ahora?
Regresar a las instituciones autóctonas de África,
y es aquí que encargamos a los Chitas que vayan a los sectores informales,
a los sectores tradicionales -
allí es donde encontrarán a la gente africana.
Y quiero mostrarles este rápido y pequeño video
respecto del sector informal, respecto de la construcción de botes
que yo, yo mismo, traté de movilizar a los africanos en la Diáspora
para invertir en ello.
¿Puede por favor mostrarlo?
Los hombres salen a pescar en esos pequeños botes.
Sí, es una empresa.
De un empresario ghanés local, usando su propio capital.
No obtiene asistencia de su gobierno,
y está construyendo un segundo bote, más grande.
Un bote más grande significa que más peces serán atrapados y traídos.
Significa que puede emplear a más ghaneses.
También significa que puede generar riqueza.
Y entonces tenemos lo que los economistas llaman
efectos externos en la economía local.
Y todo lo que tienes que hacer, todo lo que las élites tienen que hacer,
es mover esta operación a un algo, que esté cerrado
para que la operación sea más eficiente.
Ahora, no sólo es el sector informal -
también está la medicina tradicional.
80 por ciento de los africanos todavía dependen de la medicina tradicional.
El sector moderno de salud ha colapsado totalmente.
Vamos, esta es un área - quiero decir, que hay un rico tesoro
en el área de la medicina tradicional.
Aquí es donde tenemos que movilizar a los africanos,
en la Diáspora particularmente, para invertir en ello.
Necesitamos también movilizar a los africanos en la Diáspora,
no sólo de entrar en los sectores tradicionales también,
si no entrar en la agricultura e instigar el cambio desde dentro.
Pudimos movilizar a los ghaneses en la Diáspora
para instigar el cambio en Ghana y traer la democracia a Ghana.
Y yo sé que con los Chitas, podemos retomar África,
un poblado a la vez.
Muchas gracias.
(aplauso)